welcome back to the stronger by science
of fireside chat series I am your host
Greg knuckles joined today with a very
special temporary guest host Eric
Drexler Eric thanks for joining us thank
you for inviting me and everyone who has
been spamming Greg's inboxes begging him
to bring me back thank you for your hard
work please continue to do so in the
weeks to come
don't do that all right so let's let's
dive right into it
during the first fireside chat we talked
about movies and TV shows we're into I
mentioned that I was watching devs and
you were about to start as I understand
it you have you have now dove into the
Deb's Cinematic Universe what have you
felt so far yes so in a moment of just
absolutely absurd hypocrisy in the first
fireside chat I talked about how films
are way too long of a commitment for me
two hours to me is completely off the
table which is why I watch more
television than movies and I just it was
a total hypocrite and binge watched the
hell out of devs so I am fully caught up
in only like a day or two of watching
which is just so embarrassing and
shameful but it is really good this is
like right in my wheelhouse I love it so
far but I am falling into my old trap
which is I think I really love the
characters that you're not supposed to
love like we talked about in Wes world
how I just love the character of William
like old William and in this one I I can
tell that I'm again rooting for all of
the worst people but but I've grown to
accept that about myself but we're both
big time teen Kenton right Oh big time
team Kenton for sure and and Nick
Offerman his character is fantastic
complicated complex you don't it's hard
to categorize him as a good guy or a bad
guy I think maybe or maybe I'm a
sociopath is is that fair to say yeah I
mean I wouldn't necessarily say he's a
good or bad guy like okay he's someone
who's driven to do extreme things by
intense
emotional trauma like that that makes
for an interesting character who their
motives if even if not like even if I'm
not fully able to empathize with them
I think I can at least understand them
yeah and one of the things I love about
the show of course the plot is exciting
and interesting and there's a lot of
depth to it but the character
development is fantastic and sometimes
the characters do make surprising
decisions but when they do it's on
character so it has to be surprising and
yet explainable based on the characters
makeup and and I love when that is part
of a show that's the reason why I
completely turned on Game of Thrones and
was absolutely disgusted by the final
season I thought the last season of Game
of Thrones was awful and I know you
agree with me on that one yeah I'll
never forgive what what they did to
Jaime Lannister he had such an
interesting arc of character development
and redemption and then just completely
throws it all away
Wow breaking Brienne of Tarth heart
which I won I don't know that I can
forgive Jaime for that too I definitely
can't forgive the showrunners for making
him do that yeah the writing it was just
like you know what we're out of time
let's just cut some corners which is so
disappointing
but yeah so devs is absolutely awesome
I'm really stoked about it and now I'm
because I irresponsibly got fully caught
up now I have to wait for the next
episode to come out which is horrific
have you started on season three of
ozark yet no I haven't all right so it
uh it just came back yesterday dude so
season three is off to a good start so
far we've watched the first two episodes
and again we're not trying to spoil
anything but I do just want to say okay
so we were talking about how our
favorite characters and stuff are often
people who you're maybe not supposed to
root to root for right who's your
favorite character in ozark oh man
I like the Mason Bateman's character I
like his character that makes sense you
guys are are pretty similar
not because we launder money I mean
if you got if you got sucked into the
criminal world I could see you being a
money launderer like that that seems
like it would fit your personality fair
enough
my favorite hands-down is Ruth Lang more
okay she is she's quite possibly my
favorite television character just
period like really dude cuz like she
just doesn't give a [ __ ] and I I
appreciate that you'll you'll see so
second episode of season three she does
something which again is is very on
character which is just just chefs kiss
like it's yeah I saw someone on Facebook
say something about Ruth doing something
surprising and I immediately scrolled
away from it because I didn't want any
any spoilers yeah she's she's great
awesome now so we wanted to touch base
about that from last episode another
thing was we both kind of mentioned that
we are a bit curmudgeonly and someone
follow it up and said in what way you
know what are the things that really
bring out your inner curmudgeon and
really grind your gears so what what
what are yours so there are a few things
I'm I'm not really that curmudgeonly I
don't think I tell people I am but I
don't I don't know dude like I'm I'm
generally a pretty easygoing guy I do
think I'm finally starting to get to the
age that I look at what like teenagers
are doing these days and I'm like yep
just don't understand youth culture
anymore but I feel like that's not
necessarily curmudgeonly like I think
that if you fully understand youth
culture by the time you're closing in on
30 you work with kids in some capacity
and are like force to understand youth
culture to some degree or you're just
like trying to hold on to your your
adolescence a little bit too long so I
guess I'm kind of curmudgeonly in that
regard but things that do legitimately
grind my gears and get under my skin is
like one and I've done this to myself
but
one of the things that me a lot is when
people are just lazy in general and
especially lazy about acquiring
information so if you've read content on
stronger by science you know that we we
tend to opt for longer form stuff and I
try to not waste words like if there's
something that I can say in 3,000 words
I'm not just gonna make something 5,000
words for the fun of it cuz that you
know that's more time spin typing and we
also do have generally like a summary of
what an article is about at the
beginning and end of the article and so
when we publish something and I like to
get shared on Reddit and there's like a
dozen people saying this is long can you
give me a tldr it's just like no like
one we've already kind of given a tldr
at the beginning and end of the article
and then - like if I can make it
substantially shorter I would have so
like either just read it or don't
acquire the information like don't don't
force me to summarize this again I get
kind of curmudgeonly about that another
thing that I get pretty curmudgeonly
about is having to explain things
multiple times when I know I did a
pretty good job explaining things the
first time around so one thing I know
about myself is that I'm not always the
clearest communicator and so like if
someone asks me to explain something and
I'm like midway through explaining it I
know when I'm doing a piss-poor job of
it and so I think in a situation like
that when it does when it doesn't sink
in the first time you know I'm not gonna
get upset with people like I know I
[ __ ] up but if I do a good job
explaining something and someone asked
me to explain it again that's fine if
they ask me to explain it a third time
I think I'm pretty good and not letting
them see how angry I am but like at that
point just a switch flips and I'm very
angry and then the last thing that I'm
pretty curmudgeonly about his is so
I shall media so this is the thing that
I'm that I'm the biggest boomer about by
far I like Facebook and I don't like any
other social media platforms so with
Twitter like dude the character limits
like people talking about how toxic
Twitter is it's just like well the
character limit used to be 140
characters
now it's 280 but you still can't express
that much nuance and have that good of a
conversation with that few characters
like it's a platform that really lends
itself like one-liners and like
one-liners dunking on people it's not a
great platform for nuanced conversation
so like as someone who tends to write
long-form content the Twitter is so far
outside my wheelhouse I just can't I
just can't understand the platform and
like if I had a dollar for every time I
saw someone say like I'm gonna hop on
Twitter to say this this is tweet one
out of 19 and you're gonna do just do it
anywhere else clearly this is not made
for Twitter correct no and then with
Instagram like I'm coming around on the
platform slowly but surely sharing more
stuff to Instagram using Instagram
stories to share like food content but I
really really don't like Instagram for
for like fitness or business reasons
mostly because like a lot of times I'm
talking about science and you can't
share [ __ ] links on Instagram like my
enjoyment of the platform would increase
tenfold if you could put clickable links
in descriptions of posts or in comments
because then you know there's not
character well there is a character
limit but it's pretty long you know you
could you could share stuff you could
post links if you're trying to have a
discussion about something scientific
you could send people links to papers
and like that would all be fine but the
lack of that functionality on Instagram
completely ruins the platform for a
whole lot of applications for me
so like yeah I still like Facebook it's
like it's like me and people who are
forty five-plus like we're the last
Facebook holdouts and at least until
Instagram gets gets links I think that's
going to continue to be the case yeah I
mean I mean you make fair points that's
for sure
now I I don't really see you as a
curmudgeon like you said I think you're
- you're too laid-back and generally
jolly to be a true curmudgeon I am
definitely a curmudgeon that's for sure
but I think a lot of people based on my
general curmudgeonly outward appearance
they think like wow that guy's dead
inside it's just minor grumpiness it's
not like the deep deep like absolute
despair like that would appear on my
face so if you're worried about me don't
worry it's cool but there are I'm
definitely generally grumpier and more
curmudgeonly than you are okay so can I
cut in real quick sure I don't actually
think you're that curmudgeonly oh I'm
hiding it well so I think you so I very
much agree like you're you have
described yourself as having resting
crisis face which which is a very very
apt description like you either look
like everything or like everything
within you emotionally is crumbling or
that you're very very concerned about
something
those are your two resting facial
expressions so I think you appear very
curmudgeonly but like you're not
curmudgeonly to interact with yeah I am
wondering if my self perception of me
being a curmudgeon is based on people
reacting to my outward appearance and me
just accepting like oh I guess this is I
guess this is me now one of the things
we bonded about in a PL way back in the
day was like I have a very dark
sarcastic sense of humor and when I
enter a new environment I i'll start
like feeling people out I'm like who can
i really be myself around that you know
I can make a dark joke and they'll find
it funny and also not think that I'm a
terrible
person for making this joke and like you
and Mike were were the two people in
that environment who who I identified
very quickly that like okay like they
get it so I mean like it could just be
that our personalities mesh well yeah I
feel like we have similar senses of
humor and that at least around me you're
not super curmudgeonly and before I was
I was a little bit concerned because
like you were an employee and I was like
is he doing this out of obligation but
like now you're a partner in the
business so like if you're faking it at
this point you're wasting your time yeah
no okay yeah you raise good points there
but the things that get under my skin
that really grind my gears
number one is inefficiency of any kind
and you've probably picked up on this
whenever we talk about something within
the business there it can never be like
a one-off fix I'm always like you know
we have to have a repeatable process in
place for everything like you've
probably picked up on that inefficiency
of any kind drives me nuts I was like
that as a researcher I'm still like it
today I'm gonna die like that loud stuff
[Music]
dude how are we friends dude so I I grew
up in a household that was very loving
it was it was an awesome upbringing but
it I grew up in a quiet house if
anything loud was happening there was a
problem interesting and I think that
really carried over into my adulthood
where like even in like circumstances
where things are fine if things are too
loud I'm like hey everybody needs to
take it down several notches it like
makes me viscerally angry when things
are very loud so how do we get along cuz
like my normal speaking volume is a low
yell I've adapted to it Farren I've
adapted to it number three people who
are very confident about what they're
saying for no reason like that
I am so careful about what I say and so
I there is nothing that drives me crazy
er than someone who's just absurdly
confident about their hot take and I'm
like
why did you even believe that you should
be confident about your take on this
that drives me nuts I feel that one
viscerally yeah cuz that man we're way
too careful about the way we speak and
then you just go on social media you're
like dude where are you getting this
take from where is this confidence
coming from so I don't mind hot takes at
all but I feel like yeah I feel like the
confidence with which those takes come
out very strongly dictate how I react to
them that you know if someone's just
like you know I don't know [ __ ] about
this topic but here's how it seems to me
like I'll take that yeah like I don't
care if you if you throw out something
that you admit is a hot take and you're
very wrong about it but yeah people who
clearly don't know [ __ ] about something
who are incredibly confident about it
yeah that's that's that's not good it's
crazy and now I'm at my final one too
much socializing I have I have a
everyone has their own like number right
the amount of social interaction they
can have in a given time frame and still
feel good not feel fatigued by it mm-hmm
my number is way lower than everyone
else's
like it's something that I picked up
from my father he and I have talked
about it but like he and I both thrive
in silence and solitude
so like the baseline amount of social
interaction that most people need just
to get by is like about my limit and if
I go be like if I do to social things in
the same week I'm exhausted
like I gotta like take a day off or
something so for whatever reason if I
don't have my time where it's just me
alone in silence I go crazy so those are
my only lists there so this is wonder
this is making me like introspect and
wonder if at my core I'm just a deeply
sadistic person because Lindsay's that
way too
she's also I don't think she's as
introverted as you but she's she's quite
introverted and so here here is a hot
take I'm gonna throw out there the
myers-briggs personnel
which a lot of people base their entire
personhood on it's it's basically
astrology for middle management it's
completely worthless in my humble
opinion now I've talked to people in the
psych field who are like dude I can't
believe people still use it yeah so
anyway with that caveat out of the way
when I have taken the myers-briggs I am
the most extreme extrovert possible well
and I guess that is one that's actually
more validated because like that's in
big five as well yeah I am an extreme
extrovert and the two people who I spend
the most time around are like I think
Lindsay is not as extreme as an as an
introvert can be but she's she's very
introverted yeah
and you are as well so I I wonder if if
I'm a terrible person and I just derive
joy from forcing socializing on to you
guys I don't know maybe that's possible
okay so I do want to keep things moving
here now later we are going to talk
about dating and relationship advice so
I want to tease that segment because I
know that's why everybody's here that's
that's the most requested topic for us
to talk about before we get to that
somebody asked us to reflect on some
games that we like things like video
games board games stuff like that so
Greg what kind of games are you into
these days not a ton so when I was
growing up I used to be pretty into
video games one of the things I still
hold against my parents actually is most
of my friends had Nintendo systems so
when I was young
Nintendo or like the old NES and the
Super Nintendo and then most of them got
in 64 's and then game cubes and I very
much enjoyed playing Nintendo games my
parents got together with like my
friend's parents and they were like our
kids should have the diversity of video
games to play when they go over to each
other's houses so my parents only got me
Sega systems which like you know if
very much first world problems but uh so
like I enjoyed the sonic games but like
and I really enjoyed Streets of Rage
growing up for for the Sega Genesis
there were a few Dreamcast titles I
enjoy but like dude if you compare the
game library on the Dreamcast to the n64
like it's it's not even close but then I
got a ps2 in high school and I played a
lot of Madden and some some time
splitters - that was first-person
shooter game really enjoyed it but yeah
I I stopped playing video games for four
years when I went to college I wanted to
be able to focus on my studies and take
all of that seriously so I didn't bring
a TV didn't bring any game consoles and
didn't play video games from the time I
went to college until I'd been out for
probably three years give or take and at
that point you know I'm buying my own
video game system so I got a Wii U I was
apparently the only person in the world
who bought a wii u such a terrible
marketing campaign but I got it just to
play Mario Kart and smash and since then
I've gotten a switch and so will will
occasionally play some Mario Kart if
people are over and want to play like
that's a very you know that's a that's a
game that's friendly to people of all
skill levels when I'm just playing by
myself which I don't play a ton of video
games still but when I do just like kick
back and play something it's often Mario
maker these days so it's like it is a
Mario game where Nintendo made some
levels but it's mostly user made content
and so if you're if you're into 2d
platforming like there's a ton of
utterly [ __ ] Mario maker levels but
then there are a lot that are really
really good in high quality and it's so
there are some levels that are super
super hard and I really enjoy playing
those because I get a great sense of
satisfaction when I get past an obstacle
that kills me like 30
times beforehand so I play a reasonable
amount of Mario maker I don't play a ton
of smash anymore because none of my
friends play smash like if there were
people who live too near me who I was
buddies with that were also into smash I
would play a ton of smash ultimate but I
don't play enough to to make online fun
because like online smash it seems like
there's two tiers of people there's like
complete scrubs who I just utterly
destroy to the point that it's not fun
and then there are people who like as
soon as you you take over into elite
smash online then there's a bunch of
people who you know you can tell put 30
times more hours into the game than you
do and they beat me so badly it's not
fun so I'm at this like weird skill
level and smash that I just can't get
too much enjoyment from playing it
online but I do enjoy smash games in
general and then in terms of non video
game related things I love playing
trivia so generally when I'm leaving the
house on a regular basis I'll play pub
trivia every week and in terms of board
games I'm not a big board game guy but
there is one that I like and everyone
around me hates called tri bond which is
essentially like it's kind of trivia ish
so you roll the dice and like one of the
dice where one of the dies gives you a
category and the other one is how many
spaces you get to move if you get the
question correct and all of the
questions are what do these three things
have in common and so there's some
degree of trivia knowledge that you need
so you know if it's like obscure authors
and it's like oh they're all authors
from this particular time period or
whatever and then there's so my favorite
category and tri bond is riddles in
wordplay because it's like you know
purely trying to find like a creative
associations between three things that
don't seem like they would be related so
I really like try bond
pretty much everyone else I know
just despises it but I think it's fun
how about you yeah so I didn't even
think of trivia as being a game for some
reason I don't know why but I do enjoy
when we play trivia you know we go out
to the bar we reliably get third or
fifth place one of the two I don't think
we've ever gotten four it's always third
or fifth but that's fun but honestly I
generally speaking I have a visceral
hatred for games they drive me crazy
like I need to either be a hundred
percent into something or not at all and
I don't mean like oh yeah I'm pretty
competitive once we get rolling I'm
gonna be really absorbed by the game I
mean like for six months it has to be a
large focal point of my life you know
what I mean yeah like I can't just
passively be like oh yeah let's dive
into this game and have fun with it I
have to be very very serious about it I
have a very addictive personality so I
would be like you mentioned those two
tears of the games if I got out into it
I would have to be at the top tier it
would be a huge portion of my life at
that point so I think it's best for me
to just abstain from games as a general
concept and like honestly you know like
one of the things I love doing you know
every year I try to make time for a ski
trip and I like to go up to West
Virginia and go skiing and I always
think in the back of my head oh I'm
gonna be up in the mountains in a cabin
I should bring like a board game or a
deck of cards or something mm-hmm I have
before never even thought about touching
them I'll just sit in a chair and stare
at the mountains in complete silence for
an hour before I would even dream of
playing a game so it just doesn't really
fit my personality type unfortunately no
I mean that's fair that's that's kind of
how I am with boarding card games for
the most part I find try bond engrossing
for reasons I can't fully describe but
my family growing up really liked board
games really liked card games so so my
parents were both really into a card
game which I have found out now that
I've gotten older most people have never
heard of but it's called rook and they
just loved it and so I would like
begrudgingly play it with them but I was
by
for the person getting the least
enjoyment out of that and then my so one
of my grandmother's plays what's it
called oh dang it what what is the name
of that game your grandmother plays it
spades maybe is that a game I don't know
a bridge that's a thing might be bridge
I think it's bridge yeah yes she plays
like ranked competitive bridge yeah and
so when we hang out with them we play a
lot of bridge and I actually find that
really fun because you know that's like
a large part of her life and so when we
[ __ ] up [ __ ] which happens virtually
every hand she'll explain like why she
did what she did and what we should have
done that would have been the better
play and so I think I find the learning
experience a lot more fun than the
actual plane of the game but yeah in
general I'm I'm not really big into
border card games yeah alright so moving
on we're gonna get to the topic everyone
came here for dating and relationship
advice and fun fact when we started the
podcast we made it about you know
lifting and science and stuff we
actually considered just making a love
focused podcast so it's nice for for us
to be right in our sweet spot where we
can really get into these topics yeah I
don't know why anyone would ask us for
dating a relationship advice
it was the most asked off-topic thing to
talk about I fight for I think they just
want to listen to a squirm and try to
pretend that we have anything useful to
give but in any case we're gonna talk
about dating first and then we're gonna
talk about relationship advice now Greg
your approach to dating I think it's
fair to say is a bit old-school is that
right uh yeah so here you know I'm not
necessarily making a recommendation here
I'll just tell you what worked for me so
and what one thing I'll say before we
get going this is all going to be advice
from
Sibley male perspective but it's not
because we don't care about female
perspectives when a lot of dating and
relationship questions came in I have
been imploring my wife to to hop on
these fireside chats or at least the
ones related to dating and relationships
just you know one so there would be a
perspective for the ladies and two so it
wouldn't just be like you know two dudes
just probably giving [ __ ] advice but
anyway she she has said no dozens of
times so that's where we're at and if
you're upset about how this segment goes
blame Lindsey yeah also my girlfriend
was even more adamant about not being on
it than Lindsey she pretended to not be
totally averse to it when you asked her
but yeah she was very averse to you it's
it's not a competition Erik fair enough
okay so okay give us give us your advice
yeah yeah so this isn't necessarily
advice but like I said this is what
worked for me so find a nice young woman
ideally around 16 years old and if
possible you know just just stick just
stick with them marry them and live
happily ever after that's that's what I
did and it's been good now you said 16
years old it's probably important to
mention your age at the time yeah so
that's an important detail I was 17 so
my wife was my high school sweetheart
you know if if you're listening to this
and you're somewhere somewhere in your
20s and 30s do not use this plan either
don't use it or you know check check
local laws do not use this plan yeah
don't don't do that
so anyway all of that is to say if
you're listening to this and you're you
know somewhere out of high school or
really in high school I don't think it's
a good idea to marry your highschool
sweetheart like I think the data on that
suggests that that typically goes poorly
so we we've gotten lucky there
and that wasn't like a jab or anything
it's it's gone very well for me but
don't don't assume that you too will
beat the odds so yeah if you're if
you're out of high school or in high
school don't probably don't do what I
did I just wanted to let you know that
at least as far as dating advice goes at
least in terms of like how to go about
getting a girlfriend anything that I
would say is at least like 12 years
chronologically out of date and also
like multiple years in terms of like
social relationships out of date so
you're gonna have to carry the load here
tracks yeah so my approach was very
different I know when you courted
Lindsay you had to call her landline at
home and oh yes so that that is
important information so here's how long
ago it was
cell phones existed but the iPhone won
Hannett launched yet like smartphones
weren't a thing and unlimited texting
wasn't already completely ubiquitous so
I think Lindsay had an unlimited texting
plan I did not and I also had very very
limited
calling minutes on my phone and so for
probably the first year of our
relationship most of the way we would
stay in touch would be I would ask my
parents like hey do you need our
landline phone for the next hour so and
if they said no then I would shoot
Lindsay a text and say hey I'm about to
call try to be the one that picks up cuz
you know that was only one text and that
was fine and then I'd call and
invariably it would be her father who
picked up he was I
I swear during those days he was just
like pacing around the house with like
with a phone in his hand just just
waiting for me to call so Rick would
answer and I'd say hello mr. ruble may I
speak to your daughter
and so you know that that kind of dates
my dating experience I feel like I would
have a lot more to talk about with
someone who's approximately 60 years old
when it comes to dating and courtship
than someone who's three years younger
than me
I think so yeah so so yeah you take it
away from here yeah so I have a much
more modern approach to dating big
caveat here like I said earlier I am not
the person to ask about dating advice
whatsoever
I am fortunate to be in a very healthy
and happy relationship at the moment so
that's not a reflection on my current
relationship but I certainly don't see
myself as someone to be giving
unsolicited dating advice by any means
but but it was solicited it was
solicited that's true is very strongly
solicited and that's your guys's fault
yes and so I'm also gonna share like
Greg said just my experience is no
judgement date whoever you want to date
everyone be safe and happy and do do
your thing but this is from my
perspective you know in my experience
dating so I use the apps you got the
tinder and the Bumble and whatever else
is out there I don't I don't really know
there's a bunch of other ones but I
don't know all of them but those are the
two that I have used in the past and
that seems to be what the kids are up to
these days is is using the young folks I
should say is using the apps and I mean
it seems like everybody's using them
honestly and I don't know it's an
efficient way to kind of you know meet
some people and see if you have any kind
of shared interest in connection but one
of the key things there is making the
profile you basically with these apps
you get to try to decide what people see
of you it's not like when you're out at
a bar and someone sees you just
objectively for what you look like that
day you are basically cultivating this
profile image and one of the big tips
there is do not pretend to be way cooler
and way more interesting than you really
are that's a really bad plan so like if
all of your pictures and your
description are like you being the
coolest person in the world doing all
these interesting things but that's not
really you it's probably not going to
end well you're probably going to be
very underwhelmed
if you actually are fortunate enough to
go on some dates with somebody and then
they find out oh you're way less cool
than I thought so when it comes to your
profile I think you save yourself a lot
of trouble by just trying to make it
reflect as close as possible who you
actually are now you made a perfect
profile people love it
you start messaging some people a few
points on the messaging aspect of this
stuff first of all be original so if
you're making the first move you know
making the first comment their comment
about their interests hopefully they
have a profile with some interesting
information or maybe one of their
pictures they're doing something that's
identifiably interesting make a comment
about that
don't be cliche don't use one of the
copy-paste like hey here's a clever
generic opening line be original and
make it about them not some you know
cliche copy-paste kind of thing another
thing and this is really important Gregg
don't be a revolting human being you're
a person who's talking to another human
being that is a person so try to keep
that in mind you know just from like my
friends and from like you know viral
posts that that gets screenshotted and
stuff people behave very strangely on
some of these apps Gregg yeah I mean I'm
sure you've seen them on you know people
share it all over the like social media
so if if anyone out there is listening
and they're like uh I don't know can it
really be that bad a Twitter account
worth potentially checking out and so
you know these are submitted and curated
interactions so they are probably the
worst of the worst so just keep that in
mind
but just just to see how low the bottom
of the barrel is there's a Twitter
account called she rates dogs that is
it's managed by a young woman where
other young women typically submit like
screenshots from messaging apps or
dating apps and she shares the worst
ones and like whole buddy like it's
there's some bad [ __ ] out there yes
there there definitely is
what it why is it called she rates dogs
so okay there's another popular Twitter
account called we raid dogs yeah which
is exactly what it sounds like it's you
know you submit a picture of a dog and
they they rate the dog and all of the
dogs get very high ratings because all
dogs are fantastic correct so it's just
kind of a play on that but like it's
it's I guess this is kind of a dated
expression at this point but like what
people would say back in like the 80s or
90s or probably 1940s like men are dogs
so I got it back when you were dating
yeah sure so it's so it's it's a play on
that okay that makes sense so follow
we're eight dogs that is that is a very
good vibes Twitter account that everyone
should be following that that sounds
like some really good advice there so
anyway just be be respectful when you're
messaging people remember that you're
talking to a human being like come on
behave yourself out there okay now a
couple things to look out for on dating
apps and some of these I'm not even
gonna tell the story I'm just gonna give
the the takeaway point okay what to look
out for on these dating apps there are
gonna be a lot of people on these things
who broke up with someone about four
days ago that seems to be a thing a lot
of people do is like they just got out
of a big relationship it was messy and
they're like I'm gonna get back out
there so if you're like looking for
someone to really strike a strong
relation like a long-term relationship
with that's something to be kind of keep
an eye out for is like someone who broke
up with a serious you know partner like
three days ago they're probably not
ready for that so that's something to
keep in mind watch out for people who
are more married than they seem to be
[Laughter]
and it's a good little a good litmus
test if you're wondering am I too
married to present myself as single
could you get married today if you were
to go to the courthouse and they would
say sorry you can't get married because
you're already married
you're probably too married to say that
you're not married that's the litmus
test I use it by the way if you're in an
open marriage not judging whatsoever but
you know but yeah presenting yourself as
being totally single when you're very
much married that's not a good move the
full story behind that piece of advice
is way better than the reader or then
our listeners could ever conceive of but
I assume that's where you're leaving it
that's gonna be where I leave it yeah
that's probably for the best that's
probably for the best
another thing let's say you're going on
a date with someone you don't know them
very well okay
if you're going to pull a firearm out of
your bag you should probably give
someone a heads up and just to be very
clear about that story Rick was held at
gunpoint I wasn't held at gunpoint
nor did I get a gun pulled on me but
basically this story was someone I did
not know very well I was like I'll walk
you walk you to your car it's dark out
you know it's kind of a long walk
dangerous walking alone at night that
kind of thing and man before I could
even if before I knew what happened
there's a gun out of a bag I'm like whoa
what's happening here so but you know I
have no issues with guns whatsoever I'm
all for people you know feeling safe and
protecting themselves but man if you're
gonna bring a gun into someone's home
and you know pull it out of a bag
probably I think it'd be polite to give
them a heads-up am I wrong on that yeah
I don't seems like etiquette I don't
know that it's legally required but it's
uh it's polite ya know if you're pulling
it on them then presumably they might
deserve it
so then you don't necessarily have to
announce it but I was just being the
gentleman saying hey I'll walk you back
to your car and they're like yeah
believe me I'll be fine and all of a
sudden there's a gun out I'm like whoa
what's happening here but yeah so keep
an eye out for those key things when
you're on the apps and you should be in
good shape I've met plenty of really
fantastic people on the apps including
my current girlfriend like I said it's a
very healthy very happy relationship
there are wonderful people out there but
those are some of the key things to keep
an eye out for what
what is the scene like I mean this is
something that has no relevance to my
life anymore so like I don't know like
what percentage of relationships start
on apps versus you know in real life or
or other means do you do you know that
right off the top of your head cuz
because it feels like every single
friend that I have is currently on
dating apps and everyone who's currently
dating met the person they're dating
through a dating app like it is is that
almost like a monopoly on the dating
market these days or do you know you
know I don't know any numbers but I will
say my subjective experience has been
that most of my friends that are single
are on one or more apps some are more
more active than others some people just
kind of curiously swipe and never really
intend to like need somebody on them but
they do seem to be remarkably common and
honestly I think they're fantastic for a
couple reasons being serious here like I
said very efficient where you can really
just kind of survey like okay who's out
there so that that's good for people
that are really busy and you know I have
been busy my whole life because I
couldn't survive if I wasn't I'd go
crazy but so if you're busy or if you
just want to be efficient with your time
it's good for that another thing that's
good about it honestly is that I don't
like approaching someone in expressing
interest like unselect and making that
first move in public sometimes I feel
rude like even if I'm being very polite
and respectful I'm like well if this
person doesn't want me to approach and
then I feel I feel like I'm kind of
bothering them does that make sense yeah
I guess but but I so with the apps
clearly everyone is opting in if that
makes sense so I know I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with approaching
someone respectfully expressing interest
and then saying oh cool no problem but
I'm you can tell I'm assuming I got
turned down 100% in that scenario but
like I just don't like it's nice knowing
that if I'm going to express interest
the person on the other end of that has
already opted in to being in that dating
universe if that
that makes sense yeah yeah all right
should we move on to the actual
relationship advice sure so you scored a
date and now what Greg okay so I
actually do have things to say about
this because I have been in a row I have
been in a relationship more recently
than 2008 which was the last time I was
in the dating market so the first thing
I'm gonna lead with which is I feel like
something that everyone's parents have
told them and just like it's almost
cliched at this point but proper
communication is key and the proper
amount of communication is generally an
enormous amount of communication the
better you understand just the other
person like who they are and what makes
them tick what's going on in their lives
what they like and don't like how they
feel about certain things the better
things are probably going to go so
communication is key and you know both
quantity and quality matter a lot
next thing is some degree of that
communication will probably be fighting
or arguing and I am naturally a pretty
argumentative person and I think that
it's I think that it's important
especially for men and I'm not trying to
stereotype too much here but I feel like
for for myself and like just a lot of
men generally it's easy to forget in an
argument about whether you're just about
the fact that like the other person's
feelings are on the line in the argument
and it's not just purely an argument
about factual information and so like
well I did read on the Internet the
facts don't actually care about your
feelings is that true that is true but
maybe you should care about other
people's feelings just as an important
caveat correct and so you know you're
not
necessarily going into an argument to
try to win the argument and if you go
into an argument with the intent to
always win the argument you can very
much win a Pyrrhic victory like you win
the battle but lose the war like you win
the argument but then they're super
pissed at you and so you don't feel good
about winning the argument you know what
I mean
like you you lost more than you gained
yeah so always keep the other person's
feelings in mind and also like if things
do start getting argumentative and
heated just like try to take a breath
and think 1 what what is the likelihood
that I'm wrong here or just like am i
factually wrong and to what degree am i
wrong and then to probably more
importantly like how much does it matter
so you know like if you're if you're
totally in the right but like feelings
are running high and like all of the
factual information of the cases on your
side but ultimately it doesn't matter
who actually wins or loses the argument
sometimes just fold you know like like
ultimately if you're in a committed
relationship with someone and you care
about them both of you coming out of
that fight slash argument with with
generally good vibes and good feelings
about the other person matters way more
than who actually wins and loses the
argument so just just keep that in mind
next thing I'll say and I guess this
applies to both being in a relationship
with someone and probably just dating in
general is take time to at least kind of
understand and be somewhat conversant in
whatever your partner is interested in
and that doesn't necessarily need to
apply to everything but you know so for
example if you're dating a lovely young
woman and she's super into like real
housewives or something like that and
all of her female friends are really
into real housewives and she has those
people to talk about that show with and
she's not trying to talk about Real
Housewives with you all the time you
probably don't really need to know about
Real Housewives but you probably
shouldn't need to know about you know
what's going on with her job and like
who her co-workers are so like when she
comes home from work and wants to talk
about work stuff and interpersonal
relationships at the office you
understand that stuff well enough that
one you can you can listen and get what
she's saying and to that like you can
ask questions that show that you
understand what's going on and so you
know it's not just like working and her
personal stuff but if there's something
that you can tell that the person you're
in a relationship with cares about and
is passionate about and they at least
semi frequently try to bring it up in
conversation with you if you don't know
[ __ ] about it take time to learn
something about it you know that one
will help with communication that gives
you something else you can talk about
and two it just shows that you care
about them enough to put forth the
effort to care on some level about the
same stuff they care about another piece
of advice I would give
and this also does apply to both being
in a relationship and probably dating as
well is like people like to talk about
themselves that's that's most people's
favorite topic of conversation because
you know there are some people who are
completely selfless but most individuals
out there in the world are fairly
self-interested you know that applies to
me that probably applies to you dear
listener and that probably applies to
90% of the people you know so an
important skill both in relationships
and just for maintaining friendships and
making new friends is try to develop the
skill of like helping people talk about
themselves without it feeling like
you're interviewing them so if you just
go into a conversation with a list of
questions like I'm going to ask them
where they're from I'm going to ask them
what they do and you just kind of like
jump from one one subject to the next
and you're just asking them a question
cold then that can come across as creepy
like why is this person trying to glean
so much information about me but you
know if you can get them talking and you
get good at just asking innocuous
follow-up questions to allow them to
keep talking about themselves that's
that's a good tip just to get most
people to like you in general and that's
smart
yeah it's it's a good tip for
relationships and you don't have to be a
[ __ ] sociopath about it like this
would be a good skill a good skill to
master for sociopaths which I think it
comes naturally to them but like if you
care about people and you want to make
friends like you could you can do this
in a way that like you see arete eclis
if you care about developing a
friendship with someone these questions
you're asking you do actually care about
the answer to them right you're not
purely doing it just to get someone to
like you right but it will generally
help people like you another piece of
advice I would give in again like so
here here's just like kind of an aside
being in a relationship and like being
in a friendship and being just a
generally decent person
those aren't completely different things
so like what will make you a interesting
good person will generally help any
relationship you're in romantic or
otherwise but another just general piece
of advice I would give to people is have
a handful of interesting stories that
you can tell well so like dude I've
talked about this on the podcast before
I am one of the most boring people you
will ever meet I don't do that much
that's interesting but I'm not bad at
telling stories and I've lived long
enough that I've done a handful of
interesting things and a handful of
crazy things have happened to me and so
like when I meet a new person so I guess
this is this would be more like a dating
thing than like a you've been in a
relationship with someone for months
thing but this also helps with like
making friends
have a few interesting stories you can
tell about yourself and get pretty good
at telling them that will automatically
make you come across as more interesting
even if you're not all that interesting
um just it kind of helps generate good
vibes early and let's see that's a
really good tip for dating back when I
was dating more frequently I would have
a few stories that were like my go-to z'
where I was like if the conversation
gets a dull I know I can tell this story
and it's gonna be engaging and fun and
at the very least we'll have a good time
oh yeah that's really smart yeah and
then last piece of advice I'd give is
and again this this applies in
relationships but it also just applies
to being an interesting person who can
make and maintain friendships is develop
useful skills like try to be a
well-rounded person who you know you're
like the entire thing you're bringing to
a relationship is not just that you can
be an emotional crutch for someone else
so try to develop useful skills and then
this is this is a tip for the men
interest or for the men listening for
the most part try to develop a a good
sense of humor humor and be not a sense
of humor that's just like completely
edgy and dark like you know I don't
subscribe to the whole like men are from
Mars and women are from Venus and just
like utterly and completely different
like there are very much like dudes who
have like a very clean sense of humor
and women who have like a very dirty or
dark sense of humor but like in general
I find it like the stuff I talk about
with my male friends not necessarily the
same jokes that I would make if I was in
mixed company or just like telling jokes
to Lindsay even though she does actually
have a pretty dark sense of humor like
that that's one of the things we we
bonded over but yeah like if one you
interview automatically become a more
interesting person any more fun per
to be around for anyone if you have a
pretty decent sense of humor and then
too
you'll have a much better a much easier
time connecting with and maintaining
relationships with women better for the
men out there if you if you're capable
of being funny and making people laugh
without just like saying dark and [ __ ]
up [ __ ] yeah you shouldn't view your
sense of humor as like performance art
we're supposed to like shake the
listener to their core I think it's okay
to just have some light humor but that
isn't like an artistic expression that's
supposed to really rock your
understanding of the universe yeah for
sure for sure so are those all the tips
I mean if if if we did research in
preparation for this podcast I could
probably come up with more but yeah I
mean that's what comes to me kind of
immediately you know it's probably the
best ones yeah how about you well when
we when we branch out and actually do
the love podcast you know and probably
discontinue the science and the fitness
one but but do focus on that we'll have
a lot more you know I agree we we do own
the URL I forget exactly what it is but
it's something like sex by science we do
oh uh was it New Year's Eve or was it
friendsgiving I don't know I think you
were drunk yeah oh we were all drunk
yeah we were we were hanging out with
friends imbibing some adult beverages
and we were just like yeah when this
whole fitness thing doesn't pan out
we're gonna have like a very science
focused sex business actually no one of
our friends suggested that we do that
and we were all drunk enough that we all
found that very funny and so yeah just
hopped on GoDaddy in the middle of the
conversation and bought I believe it was
sex by science as a domain name yeah so
this is all clearly a joke but if we did
ever want to go that direction we do
have a URL or if you want to go that
direction and buy the domain you can
make an offer yeah for sure
okay so I agree with your tips generally
I had a couple things that came to mind
for me without being repetitive I always
say that if I could somehow spend less
time with myself I would but like
logistical II I don't know how to make
that work but what I try to think about
in a relationship is what do I hate
about me and then I assume they probably
do to like to some level right so I try
to think like if I were dating me what
would be getting under my skin I try to
be very conscious of those things and
try to be proactive like not just say
yeah I'm the worst and and just accept
that but like actually be proactive
about am i doing annoying stuff and
trying to be try to communicate about it
say like hey am i doing that annoying
thing I always do if so how do I get
better at that and not do it as much so
try to be introspective about you know
is there anything you're doing in the
relationship that might be causing some
kind of friction you know and try to be
proactive about that before it reaches a
point where you're in a big dust-up
about it getting in a big argument can I
just add something to that real quick
yeah if you're in a relationship with
someone and you care about them and you
want to stay in that relationship if
you're not as proactive as maybe you
should be or maybe you just do something
annoying that they don't like that it
wouldn't occur to you that they don't
like when they bring that to your
attention
try not to be super defensive about it
and try not to say like oh you're just
being too sensitive that's fine
because the thing is if you're in a
relationship with that person
the only opinion about whether it's fine
or not that matters is theirs so you
know then you then you have the question
for yourself like is it worth trying to
to change this behavior to maintain the
relationship and if it's something
that's just like super quarter your
identity like cut them loose you know
there's other fish in the sea but if
your primary goal there is to maintain
the relationship like don't fight about
that like just just take it and stride
and make whatever necessary changes
there are to make to whatever degree
feasible yeah another thing you know you
mentioned you know getting to the point
where you're able to discuss some key
things that are important to your
partner you know I have been in
relationships in the past where it's
like you know of course you have to make
some compromises but if you notice that
the sphere of things that you like and
are interested in is completely separate
from the things that they like and are
interested in and you just don't have
enough of a mixture of things that you
both share an interest in that could be
bad news so like of course you need to
make compromises you know but you want
to make sure that when you're in the
process of dating and actually finding a
partner that you actually have enough
compatibility that this thing's gonna
have wheels in the long run this
relationship you know you want to make
sure you have enough compatibility and
overlapping interest that it's at least
enough to cling on to in in the years to
come if that makes sense so of course
there's gonna be some things that
they're into that you you read up on and
you become you know somewhat familiar
with it you know just just to compromise
and kind of meet them halfway on
something and that's a nice thing to do
and it's advisable but like man back in
the day I went salsa dancing way more
times than I would have liked it was
just awful I hated it so much and it was
like one of those things where we just
had like no overlap like the things that
person enjoyed and the things that I
enjoyed there was zero overlap in that
Venn diagram and it gets to a point
where it's like yeah you should make
compromises for sure but if everything
you do together is an enormous
compromise that's probably not a good
sign so like my current girlfriend like
I said very happy relationship we had a
date a few weeks ago where all we did
was talk about statistics really high
level statistics she's smarter than me
which is frustrating but that's okay but
I mean it's one of those things where of
course you know making those compromises
is important but when you're in the
dating phase try to figure out how much
of an uphill battle am I am I giving
myself here do we actually have enough
compatibility that this thing's going to
be viable you know moving forward and
the more you can find some with overlap
being interest the better I think now I
I agree and this is somewhat related
like one of the things that I mean there
aren't that many people out there asking
me about my marriage but if someone's
like if someone for whatever reason does
ask the first thing I'll always say is
just that Lindsey is my best friend and
I'm I I'm that's kind of news to me well
you're you're my second best friend
okay well third we'll talk later I mean
so Lindsey's number one you and oz water
like 2a and 2b but but no so like yeah I
think one of the important things is
just that you have enough in common with
someone that if you're trying to you
know make a relationship long term and
possibly marry the person like if
they're not legitimately your best
friend like if you know occasionally two
people just spend enough time together
that you're just like yeah like I'm
gonna go hang out with someone else but
just kind of on a on a baseline basis if
they're not your favorite person and
just chill with and just hang out with
and you don't have enough in common with
the person to make that work you're
probably gonna be in for some tough
sledding so I think that's very very
good advice all right so there you have
it that's dating in relationship advice
if you know in the future you end up
getting married
and you feel like this particular
episode was played an instrumental role
in that all we would ask is that you
invite me and Greg and Lindsey and you
know make sure you have an open bar at
the wedding and I think that would be
totally fair that's all we want honestly
that would be fun yeah what do weddings
I'm a sucker for weddings I like
weddings yeah so invite us out make sure
there's an open bar and we'll be there
and cover our plane tickets of course
correct yeah I assume that was a part of
the only all right so let's let's wrap
this thing up we're doing these fireside
chats to give you something that you can
listen to it's just a conversation
between buddies that kind of helps you
just dissociate
from you know this stuff going on in the
world right now but one thing that I
want to say that is like somewhat
related to that is a fair amount of
people who follow us on social media
listen to the podcast etc are our owners
or managers of just like small boutique
gems so CrossFit boxes like you know
garage or not garage but like warehouse
powerlifting gyms underground
bodybuilding gyms etc but if you're
going to some sort of like privately
owned boutique gym if it's like a small
community gym that you care about and
you know the owners and care about them
if it is at all within your means to do
so don't cancel your gym membership
right now like even if so look times are
tough out there for a lot of people if
you just got laid off
you don't know where money's gonna come
from and you need to cancel that gym
membership I'm a million percent not
trying to shame me for that but if it's
just a situation where you know you're
not going to be able to go to the gym
for a month or two and you're like ah
you know maybe I'll put this on hold and
not pay for the couple of months I'm not
going to be able to use this membership
if you can please don't do that
gyms tend to run on really really tight
margins if they run on margins at all
and so like you know some cities are
doing rent freezes and if if your cities
doing that that's awesome but biggest
thing here is if you can support the
local gym you go to please try to
continue to do so yeah and just to be
abundantly clear you know like you said
there's no shaming going on like times
are really tough for a lot of people
right now we have no interest in telling
you how you should spend your money
particularly if times are really tough
for you right now that's not at all the
the objective here but you know if it's
within your means and you can afford to
do so it'd be a really great thing
because those gyms really make up the
heart of lifting culture you know what I
mean it's those independent gyms where
you develop friendships where you
memories of lifting you know I've been
in and out of gyms like that where you
and the the owner see each other every
time you walk in you develop really good
friendships and they're just a really
important part of the lifting world in
the lifting culture so if at all
possible if we can do our best
collectively to keep that alive I think
it'd be a huge thing I agree
wholeheartedly and one other thing to
potentially reach out to your gym owner
about you know I'm sure not every gym is
doing this and maybe they're not doing
it just because it hasn't occurred to
the owner to do it but I've heard of
some small private gyms either loaning
out or renting out equipment to you know
anyone who wants it or in the case of
rentals whoever can afford it you know
we there are a lot of people struggling
out there without access to the iron I
totally get that if you have just like
room in your house for say a medicine
ball or an axle or whatever it might be
and you go to a gym that is willing to
either loan out or rent out equipment
and you want access to that might be
worth having that conversation with your
gym owner they may or may not be open to
it but you know if you're if you're
looking for a way to spend social
isolation not isolated from the iron
that is you know one potential thing to
think about
all right so that is it for the second
stronger by science fireside chat
we appreciate you listening if you would
like to hear us discuss something on
either the normal podcasts or these very
much off-topic podcasts feel free to
submit them at tiny CC slash SBS QA and
until next time hope you have a good one
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another healthcare
professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
you